Tim how definite is this well it's the
path has been lining up in her favor for
the last few weeks and it was
essentially all but inevitable that she
would get the delegates that she needed
heading into the convention the party's
convention this summer really the
question had been how would the
uncommitted super-delegates the party
leaders how would they how would they go
and senator Sanders had been arguing
that if he won the definitive victory in
California primary which is tomorrow
that perhaps he could persuade some of
those undecided his way the math now
would seem to be totally not in his
favor really giving Clinton a lot of
head of steam going into some important
votes tomorrow California New Jersey
really big States a lot of official or
the normal delegates that will really
just totally lock it down for her Rizzo
really even today she'd been talking
about on the trail about a being asked
that the historic nature of what she was
on the cusp of achieving the first woman
to receive her party's nomination for
the President of the United States and
she says she was focused on win in
California well you know the numbers in
the trend may have been in her favor but
that has not stopped Bernie Sanders from
remaining in this race what does this
now mean for him well we're already
seeing the pressure building on senator
Sanders to drop out of the race
Bloomberg News reported today that
President Barack Obama is expected to
endorse Clinton as soon as this week
according to people familiar and that's
the something that it would be expected
of the official the presumptive nominee
we've seen other Democratic Party
leaders come out and support of Clinton
pushing putting pressure for senator
Sanders to drop out Clinton on her
behalf however is it's been kind of
understanding saying that he essentially
her campus is saying these standards can
go there go the distance to go through
the all of the states as she did when
she ran in 2008 and lost against Obama
even though Obama had enough
the mass to win yes today she said she
you know wasn't turning to that thought
yet that she was going to let it play
out in California but as soon as that as
soon as that voting is done tomorrow you
can assume that a pressure will be very
intense for Sanders drop out yeah it
seems a little premature but still
waiting for that California primary so
it sounds like she's got 2,383 delegates
in her camp what does this mean now
about putting the party back together
this has been a very divisive end
oftentimes in in some instances a little
violent when it came to the Sanders in
Clinton camps yeah that is definitely
the the next thing on Quentin's agenda
is putting the party back together but
in some ways depending upon how Sanders
respond for the next few weeks the party
could naturally come back together
that's what we saw in 2008 Clinton
really pivoted towards bringing her
supporters into then-senator barack
obama champ and she was able to patch up
her relationship enough with obama that
he eventually appointed her as its his
secretary of state yet you know that we
saw some very tough language from
senator Sanders over the weekend talking
about how he was going to fight it out
to the convention today however he had a
press conference and maybe a little bit
of a softening of that language maybe
not as hard but you know we really will
be looking for his language tomorrow
night after the votes and kind of the
next few days is kind of tell where he's
going where his mind is